so yesterday on the world famous and
award-winning bonus show producer Pat
and I talked about the reality that
British prime minister Liz truss's days
may be numbered even though it had only
been like six weeks since she came to
power and indeed we woke up this morning
in the United States the news that
British prime minister Liz truss has
resigned after only 43 days in office
trust is a member of the conservative
party also known as the Tory party and
you started to get the sense that maybe
this wasn't going to be particularly
long-lived when the idea of cutting
taxes on the rich was first presented at
a particularly inopportune time given
what was going on in the British economy
and then very quickly abandoned it
already sort of wasn't looking
particularly good and then now indeed a
CNBC reporting UK prime minister Liz
truss resigns after failed budget and
Market turmoil that's putting it lightly
a writing that on September 23rd trust
is financed Mr Minister quasi quartang
announced a so-called mini budget which
began a turbulent period for UK Bond
markets which balked at the debt-funded
tax cuts he put forward most of the
policies were reversed three weeks later
by the second Finance Minister Jeremy
Hunt that's already a bad start and
indeed now the resignation comes amid a
financial Market turmoil and a Revolt
within the conservative party as is
often the case in politics defiant until
the very end just a day earlier check
out this video listen to this audio
defiant
saying I am not a quitter
and of course we know what happened just
hours later this is yesterday Mr Speaker
I am a fighter and not a
I have uttered in the National interest
to make sure that we have economic
stability order
I'm going to hear the Prime Minister I
suggest that all members need to hear
the answer prime minister
[Applause]
Mr Speaker
I am a fighter
we have delivered on the energy price
guarantee we have we delivered on the
energy price guarantee we've delivered
on National Insurance we are going to
deliver to stop the militant trade
unions disrupting our Railways The
Honorable gentleman has no idea and of
course ultimately what she delivered was
a resignation announcement this morning
very early U.S time uh morning time in
the UK let's take a look at that uh how
quickly political Fates can of course uh
reverse given the situation yes I can a
much a much more sober sounding Liz
truss this morning not deliver the
Mandate on which I was elected by the
conservative party
I have therefore spoken to his majesty
the king to notify him that I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party wow this morning I met the
chairman of the 1922 committee sir gray
and Brady
we've agreed that there will be a
leadership election to be completed
within the next week
this will ensure that we remain on a
path to deliver our fiscal plans and
maintain our country's economic
stability and National Security a bit
late for that actually I will remain as
prime minister until a successor has
been chosen thank you yeah it's a very
very clear and definitive resignation
there this makes Liz trust the shortest
Prime Min shortest lived prime minister
in the history of the UK the previous
shortest died rather than quit so this
is really quite significant um Liz truss
43 days and prior to Liz trust the
shortest live prime minister was George
canning whose term lasted 119 days you
have to go back to the period April 12
1827 to his death on August 8 18
27. now one perspective on and all of
this is that this is really less about
Liz truss and Boris Johnson than it is
about the disconnect between the
conservative party
and the majority
of the people in the United Kingdom and
the idea is that trust was essentially a
scapegoat and so you could kind of take
it step by step well the Tory party has
been the Tory party for a long time of
course tax cuts for the rich it's like
Republicans in that sense no matter what
you see no matter what nail or screw or
tile or piece of flooring you see your
only tool is a hammer so you figure well
I'll take the hammer to whatever it is
even if it doesn't make sense to start
hammering a tile
um and the Boris Johnson resignation was
more about his particular bad acts than
it was about policy but then sort of
seeing the writing on the wall and that
this is really not the time economically
for someone with this policy the idea is
well it was clear that whoever replaced
Boris Johnson Liz truss or whoever else
uh Mr Bean right it was going to be if
the policies were those of the Tory
party it was going to be a sort of
sacrificial lamb it was going to be
escape goat whatever to go up there and
say yeah we're still going to do the tax
cuts obviously we're not that gets
abandoned they suffer and then they move
on and now whoever is next again this is
the idea whoever is next now won't
suggest the tax cuts for the rich which
would be particularly ill-timed right
now and maybe we'll be able to have a
longer tenure the other idea is all of
this this is just going to be a loop
until eventually the conservative party
is removed from power and that it's just
a matter of time and it's just a number
of scapegoats or sacrificial Lambs
between now and then I don't know but an
extraordinary bit of global news there
43 days as prime minister imagine if we
had this sort of process in the United
States that would really be something
the science tells us that one of the
best ways to get consistent deep sleep
is lowering your core body temperature
when your body stays cooler at night
you're more comfortable and your sleep
is better our sponsor sleep me is the
home of chili sleep the customizable
climate controlled sleep solutions that
can improve your sleep by keeping you
cooler at night there are three
different chili sleep systems there's
the uler the cube and the new Doc Pro
with double the cooling power all three
systems are water-based temperature
controlled mattress toppers that fit
over your existing mattress to provide
you with your ideal sleep temperature
you can go as cool as 55 degrees you can
go really hot if you want I keep mine at
60 beautiful temperature for me
don't wake up hot and sweaty chilly
sleep keeps me asleep all night it feels
great I didn't know it was possible to
love sleeping even more than I already
did go to sleep.me slash Pacman to learn
more and get 25 off your new chili Sleep
System click the link below to start
staying cool at night